Jordan these these pills they don't work
which ones how can you tell it says open
them you know it's supposed to put you
into a long sleep I thought you asked
for zopim zopim what is that it's like
menopause or something menopause what
would I want with a menopause I don't
know I don't
St I've been accused of being an
observer a user a loner a failure and a
fool Richie I need someone to pick up
Sophia from her school recital today can
you do this for me I don't know if you
remember me but I am your
uncle you don't look really healthy do
you take vitamins I take drugs those
aren't
vitamins what are you doing I've got a
kid giving me Permanent stink eye I got
old people yelling at me I don't know
where you are I don't know where I am I
don't know what the hell is going going
on around
here you should get a girlfriend to take
care of you I you clearly can't take
care of
yourself what's going on are you all
right I don't want her to see me like
this
Richie so you grew apart what happened
was I became a bad
[Music]
person death isn't just a destination
for
you it's woven into the fabric your
soul I don't think that at all I think
you're a dumb
person I don't know what to say to her
just tell her you love
her just want to get you back home safe
just want to do one thing
[Music]
right
prise
promise you want to explain this to us
before we call the police at the time
that this incident took place I was
under the influence of a menopausal
medication I don't remember much of
[Music]
anything